Charlie spoke with the former president
yesterday right here in New York ahead
of his Family Foundation's final Clinton
Global Initiative conference he asked
the former president about the
appearance of conflicts of interests
between the Clinton Foundation and the
State Department while his wife was
Secretary of State
I've been over backwards to try to make
sure there was no conflict of interest
or appearance of conflict of interest
we reached an agreement with the White
House before Hillary became Secretary of
State about how all donations would be
handled and how the foundation would be
run and I've been working for almost a
year now trying to determine what more
we need to do so I said the other day if
she wins I resigned from the Foundation
Board I won't raise any money
we won't take any foreign money nor will
we take any American corporate money I
know you have said that some people then
when you hear you say that say then why
not do it now
why don't simply say from now on not
whether she's elected president from now
and we will not accept that implies now
resign from the board and we'll see
because there is nothing wrong with what
we're doing the I because I've got to
wind it down because it takes time to
undo this we've got a lot of lives on
the line I think people recognize the
Clinton Foundation has done a lot of
good work a lot of good work and it
spent millions of dollars number two
they recognize the play Oh mr. mr. Trump
I think well well that's mr. Trump I
think I'm talking about the American
public and I thought what phone to
people who talk about these things they
also recognize that the Clinton Global
Initiative has been a gathering of
people here in New York and other places
to talk about how to solve problems
that's a very different issue those two
things you can recognize that and still
say where there have been instances here
in which people have called members of
the foundation and said we'd like to be
at a meeting we like to be we'd like to
have a meeting with the Secretary of
State has that happened well you know
what from the emails what hasn't had
what happened and I think you know what
the State Department said there were two
instances I read about one of which the
person didn't get what they wanted and
the other of which
had gone through ordinary State
Department channels anyway now that's
what I read about and that can't happen
anymore do you believe and understand
half of some people the optics weren't
good and it had the appearance of
influence I believe that people who know
each other call each other all the time
all I know is what I read in the paper
they saw that papers indicated that
there was a presumption of suspicion if
Hillary gave a meeting to Mohamed Younis
without even bothering to call to find
out the facts
Mohamed Younis was a Nobel Prize when I
talked about those but people who were
business people who simply wanted to be
associated with the Clintons and what
happened people as secretaries none of
them get an opportunity to participate
in a medium and get an opportunity to me
first of all meetings are set up all the
time members of Congress do that all the
time members of the White House do that
all time but the State Department has
said conclusively and is offered
documentary proof insofar as it exists
that nothing was ever done for anybody
because they were contributor to the
foundation nothing you were saying with
respect to the foundation and whatever
might have taken place with his Beckman
with the foundation any access to the
Secretary of State there is nothing to
apologize for nothing happened there
were no consequences and we have been as
transparent as we should and can is that
what you're saying
I believe first of all we have been as
transparent as we can be and we've been
more transparent than any other
foundation more transparent than any
other foundation that has ever been
asked to be and certainly more
transparent than anybody else in this
line of work is I have said that to the
best of my knowledge nobody ever got
anything from the State Department
because they supported the Clinton
Foundation if they did and it was
inappropriate I would say that was wrong
too I have proved that I'm not averse to
apologizing for things that I think
we're wrong and in our next half hour
the
former president talks to Charlie about
his future including a potential role in
the White House so many times it always
seems to boil down to the optics doesn't
it of the situation it does it's it
that's a great point gal I mean this was
a really strong interview I thought
between the two of them back and forth I
think it's interesting that the former
president says and has said previously
that he would step down and Charlie
saying well why not do now stop raising
money so to prevent any you know
appearance the objects accomplished
interests but that they'd like Chelsea
to continue in that role to lead the
foundation and the good work that they
do